how to put on their windshield wipers to
get literally the oil slick off the
window
that's why i and so damn many other
people i grew up have cancer and why
can't for the longest time delaware had
the highest cancer rate in the nation
that's why i and many other people i
grew up with have cancer uh what
is
we've never really gotten a
clarification for the white house on
this does the president have cancer is
that something we should probably know
does he give cancer and covet now
that's not a good combination and he's
elderly
shouldn't we know these things the
answer is no this is how bad it's gotten
that um
you know the president said the
president united states said yesterday
that he has cancer that is what he said
and
but we're all kind of
uh assuring ourselves oh he doesn't
really have cancer he just has dementia
so he says stuff like this
so either he has either this is either
him making that statement is either due
to the fact that he really does have
cancer or oh no it's just dementia
flaring up again
come on man